tiens là la dengue et les super bizarre
qu'est ce que tu fais
regarde personne
qu'est ce que tu vas n'a rien du tout
bonsoir petit la fasch tu m'a flanqué
une peur bleue qui veut entendre un
petit truc cool
bien sûr tu sais ce que ça fait d'être
étranglé à mort d'abord tu sens la
pression sur ta gorge des yeux larmoie
tu as un goût qui remonte un goût très
très acide dans la bouche ensuite une
allumette s'allumant toi dans ta
poitrine et ensuite ensuite le feu
intérieur grossi les poumons sont envahi
sa gagnait la gorge et le tout remonte
aux yeux et enfin en dernier le feu
devient glace c'est comme des épingles
des aiguilles de glace dans des orteils
puis dans tes doigts sous tes ongles
dans tes bras tu vois des étoiles il
soudain le noir la dernière chose que tu
ressens c'est le froid
pas nuire mais en mairie
nous t'invitons dans notre cercle si
c'est toi et ta les bougies seigneur
c'est de l'art mac
elle l'a mérité et maman au travail
c'est de tenir derrière les rideaux pas
d'attaquer les clients en fait la jeune
fille y croiser l arnaque pas normal
elle a beaucoup de problèmes
rien de très inquiétant c'est quoi ça
nouvel accessoire de travail et ce qui
est ce que tu m'entends oui nous
entendre et on peut avoir aussi doris
acquise que tu parles
papa est ce que tu es là tu es qui vous
l'avez vu écrire ça non parce que c'est
du polonais doris qui a écrit ça
j'habite mon prix est qu là
il se passe des choses qu'on ne peut pas
comprendre
je suis inquiet pour votre fille
le monde des esprits est dangereux
est-ce que tu le fais tu sais ce que ça
fait un homme quand on les trempe
oui c'est devenu bizarre auquel il n'y a
pas d'hopital je pense qu'elle canalise
des puissances dont nous ignorons tout
auris
cette fois oui